hello and welcome everybody to the
Macmillan Center I'm in Shapiro the
director we're delighted to host
Minister Rory Stewart as this year's
George Herbert Walker jr. lecturer and
in uh in International Studies the
Honorable George Herbert Walker the
third Yale College class of 1953
established this lecture series in 1986
to commemorate his father a
distinguished graduate of the Yale class
of 1927 the war collection has featured
eminent practitioners and scholars
including Madeleine Albright John Major
Richard Holbrooke and un
secretary-general ban ki-moon Minister
Stewart was currently the Minister for
prisons in the UK is a member of
parliament for Penrith and the border
the largest geographical constituency in
England he's an accomplished author
senior diplomat philanthropist and a
documentary filmmaker in January 2018 he
was appointed Minister of State for the
Ministry of Justice having previously
been the Minister of State for Africa at
both the Foreign and Commonwealth Office
and the department for international
development as I said he's now moved on
to take responsibility for you said 180
prisons he said yes so we were
commenting that perhaps this is the
beginning of a like Tocqueville before
him coming to America to study the
present system which will lead to a new
book on democracy in America his
previous career was in foreign affairs
particularly focused on military
intervention and international
development while on leave from the
foreign service he worked for 21 months
crossing Iran Afghanistan Pakistan India
and Nepal in state in 500 village houses
during his journey from 2005 to 2008
Stewart was chair and chief executive of
the turquoise mountain foundation based
in Kabul where he grew up which he grew
from a hundred to three hundred
employees the
so restored a section of the old city
established a clinic primary school and
Arts Institute and he bought Afghan
crafts to the international market
Stewart has written four books the
places in between a New York Times best
seller that describes his walk across
Afghanistan in the winter of 2001 and
2002 occupational hazards or the prince
of the marshes his account of his time
as an administrator in southern Iraq the
marshes which describes a walk through
Cumbria and the borders with his father
and kin intervention work an essay on
military intervention which is close to
the subject that he's going to speak
about today as a filmmaker Stewart has
presented three BBC television
documentaries in search of Lawrence of
Arabia Afghanistan the great game and
border country the story of Britain's
lost middle land suit has been we've
been awarded the Order of the British
Empire for his work in Iraq the gold
medal of the Royal Scottish geographical
society for his work in Afghanistan the
spirit of Scotland awarded the Radio
France award the prize del Camino del
CID for his books a Scottish BAFTA for
his documentary making and honorary
doctorates from Sterling University and
the American University of Paris the
title he's chosen for today's lecture is
failed States and how not to fix them
I'm pleased to introduce Minister Rory
Stewart welcome
well thank you all very very much indeed
first thing can you hear me clearly
great um so thank you for coming and I'm
going to try to speak relatively briefly
and then turn this into more of a
conversation rather than the formal
lecture given given the size of the room
and I wanted to begin by trying to draw
out some of my own personal experience
some of my own personal experience as
somebody who went from being a
practitioner on the ground so I began my
career working in Indonesia in Bosnia
and Kosovo I then worked in Iraq and
then in Afghanistan and moved from that
to being a minister and I try to reflect
a little bit on what it means to be a
minister and I wanted to begin by
sharing with you my experience just over
a year ago a year and a half ago when I
became the minister for international
development responsible initially from
Elysee in Asia and then Africa I had a
budget for which I was responsible of
about seven and a half billion u.s.
dollars a year and I had to spend that
money every year because the British
government had signed up to spending
0.7% of GDP on international aid so
every day crossing my desk came these
business cases for different spending
decisions so any spending decision over
ten million pounds I had to sign off and
as you can imagine when you're trying to
spend a six and a half billion dollars
there's a lot of those spending
decisions so I sit there every day and
every day on my desk is would you like
to spend 220 million dollars on an
education program in Ethiopia would you
like to spend 42 million dollars on
training political parties in Bangladesh
would you like to spend 15 million
dollars on a health care projects in
Upper Tanzania right and this whole
environment this whole context
is of course something that comes out of
a very very exciting very inspirational
vision post-war vision about the role
that wealthy countries can play in the
developing world this sum of money in
fact this 0.7% of GDP spent over on
international aid reflects a huge
international commitment that began to
emerge in the 1970s when economists
calculated it of all the wealthy
countries spent 0.7 percent of their GDP
on international aid they would be able
to end poverty by the year 2000 right
this didn't quite happen but the the the
commitment remains so that Scandinavian
countries Britain are now Germany have
now met this 0.7% target and the focus
of our work of course over this period
has narrowed so whereas in the 1970s we
were very concerned with countries like
China India Indonesia Bangladesh now
increasingly we are preoccupied with
fragile states and particularly failed
states so let's just start with that as
an example and in order to do this I
need I need my chalk I have my shirt and
I have a box of chalk the professor at
firebot school and I've got very spoilt
recently because though we have
whiteboards in Britain which allow me to
write in red and blue and green but
you're just gonna have to get me
scratching and white so just going to
start by putting up on the board here as
a way of getting the conversation going
a list of countries right so that's the
Central African Republic that's the
Democratic Republic of the Congo
it's Burundi Liberia Mischa anyone like
to try to guess what those five
countries are what what those five
minutes be generally what are they
supposed to be those five countries if
you're a minister dealing with this kind
of stuff I do what well there's five
countries are okay there's sub-saharan
African countries but in addition to
that they are in terms of normal GDP per
capita they are supposed to be the five
poorest countries in the world at the
moment right and I over here I'm just
going to put another list of countries
South Sudan Somalia Yemen Chad basin
any thoughts on those for what do we got
going on there yeah this this is these
are the major humanitarian emergencies
the moment this is where the large UN
appeals are taking place appeals four to
three billion dollars this is UNICEF
World Food Program these are the big
famines which people have been leaning
into over the last couple of years right
now would anyone like to begin to
generate so imagine you are now my
position you are now the minister
responsible for International
Development you may not be spending your
six-and-a-half billion a year and you're
supposed to be addressing the issues of
these countries the poorest countries
countries where people are on the case
to the Central African Republic where
terms of GDP per capita people are
supposed to be on about two dollars a
day but it's a very unequal society so
very few people are actually making $2 a
day and you men to be dealing with these
countries in which take Somalia 2011 and
nearly a hundred and fifty thousand
people starved to death in a two-month
period including a number of children
when I was in northern Somalia last year
I went to emergency nutrition centers
where I could see children getting tubes
put in their noses by UNICEF in order to
try to keep him alive children hadn't
eaten for two it's okay so what are the
problems for these countries what's
involved in trying to deal with these
countries what are we supposed to be
doing about these countries how are you
going to spend your money can I have an
idea from the audience doesn't need to
be a very serious idea I'm just trying
to get the conversation going some
thought or infrastructure okay let's put
some infrastructure
okay now infrastructure of course is
something that we were building a great
deal in all these countries in the 1960s
and early 1970s in fact if you travel as
I did recently through the Democratic
Republic of the Congo you are
perpetually coming across roads which
were funded at various times by the US
government by the Soviet Union by the
Belgians and those roads have largely
collapsed so does anyone want to just
speculate a little bit about what the
fundamental problem has been with us
constructing infrastructure in these
countries and why building
infrastructure has already turned those
countries around please corruption okay
let's think of another problem in DRC or
indeed there another fundamental problem
yep dictators okay let's put put a put
yeah okay let's put government here yep
civil war I'm going to put security up
here all right
generate please so many more health
education food
jobs yeah clean water water yep water
yeah that's a big problem if you get too
new share yeah women so what did
somebody say that tribalism okay that's
a different kind of problem I'm gonna
put that out here all right now what
would be the basic analysis for why
despite the fact that we've spent many
many billions of dollars over the last
4050 years in those countries we haven't
actually managed to solve the problem so
any number of people from the 1960s
onwards ranging from dedicated
missionaries to USAID workers to people
working for Save the Children or the
United Nations have gone into those
countries and spent an enormous amount
of money and not a great deal has been
achieved take the next country that
would have been on the less so the sixth
wealth poorest country in the world is
Malawi Malawi is a country where the
British government for example has spent
something in the region of four and a
half billion pounds over the last 50
years and Malawi is a fairer thing
poorer than it was when we started 50
years ago what are we doing wrong what
is the problem with this whole model
yeah
okay so we've had corruption and trying
to build governments in our own image so
I'm going to put up here and this of
course is what I'm trying to move
towards the problems basically here we
normally analyze in terms of failed
states right so the analysis is
basically that it doesn't matter how
many roads you build if the government
isn't actually going to sustain maintain
and manage those roads they will
collapse pretty quickly it doesn't
matter how much you spend on health care
or education if the education system in
the country doesn't work the health care
system country doesn't work it's not
sustainable right your money is
effectively wasted unless you can begin
to address some of these issues
tribalism corruption civil wars security
government you're not going to be able
to sort these problems out right now let
me then move on to the next stage so we
have an analysis of a problem we have
some very poor countries and at the
heart of the problem is that these
countries are basically failed States we
can come later in the conversation to
defining exactly what a failed state is
but there's absolutely no doubt that
these states have a real problem with
what we might call capacity or what we
might call the JIT a'mma C or what we
might call security
they don't seem at least from their
capital cities to control their
territory in the way that we might
anticipate or expect right let's then
come to the next question
right why does this matter to us why do
we care about any of this why is any of
this important to us so I want to
suggest
okay exactly so our insecurities and
moral issues so let's break that down
let's take Africa for example why do we
get upset about Africa well we get upset
about Africa firstly because people
there are very very poor right so that
you have those 150,000 people dying in
Somalia or in a six week period but also
because at the moment in Africa we are
in a situation in which by 2050 one in
ten of the children born in the world
will be Nigerian right by the end of
this century half the world's population
will be from sub-saharan Africa at the
moment 18 million sub-saharan Africans
are joining the job market every year
and they are not getting any jobs right
if you go to Dar es Salaam in Tanzania
at the moment the unemployment rates
amongst youth well over 90 percent so if
you were trying to guess where the Syria
of the future is likely to be where the
failed fragile States future like me
they're likely to come from Africa if
you're thinking about whether migration
threats to Europe likely to be well
what's gonna happen to all these young
unemployed people who have no
livelihoods or future in Africa they're
gonna start crossing the Mediterranean
if you're worrying about where epidemics
are likely to come from because of
course epidemics is not just right a
question of a particular natural
environment it's a question of the state
structures ability to deal with it what
was the problem in Liberia Sierra Leone
with Ebola the problem for not
fundamentally was the problem of the
health system in addressing that right
now they didn't have proper clinics they
don't have proper detection systems it
was very very difficult for them to
process people when they became up so
whether you're worried about security
and the form of terrorism whether you're
very about security in terms of
migration if you're worried about
security in terms of epidemics you may
be worried about Africa and on the
positive side if you're looking for the
markets of the future it's almost
certainly to Africa that you would turn
and if there's a labor shortage in
Europe and if there's an excess capital
in Europe then the labor is in Africa if
you're interested in more materials
right nearly ten percent of the contents
of this
come from the Democratic Republic of the
Congo and Democratic Republic of the
Congo is has the world's largest
reserves of coltan of cobalt has
enormous reserves of rare earth and all
of this is going to be increasingly
important Brett so we have a situation
where we have a problem we have a
problem that has significance for us in
terms of security and our humanitarian
obligations and a potential opportunity
for us so for all those reasons we would
feel I guess that we would want to be
able to fix these failed States which
brings me to my next point
okay now imagine that you have been
given the job of trying to fix one of
these failed states let's take it down
from the nine states that I've put up
there and let's take it down just to
Somalia and imagine yourself sent out as
an advisor to the governor of a province
somewhere in central Somalia and I'm
going to paint a little picture for it
and then I'm going to give you an
opportunity to try to work out what
you're going to do about this situation
so Somalia has been through a civil war
you end up in an office it's got smashed
windows there's very little furniture
there's a fancy new laptop computer that
somehow the governor is acquired from
some USAID grant that's arrived before
you and you are being given the job of
trying to re-establish the basic
conditions of a state in order to
generate prosperity employment security
and a sustainable future for Somalia
right and you are you right
you are some form you are employed by
USAID well you're employed by the World
Bank all you're employed by UNICEF well
you're employed by Save the Children are
employed by Oxfam and you've been dumped
here and you're trying to fix this
failed state okay and you turn up in the
governor's office day one just smart
clothes on right and you're gonna have a
conversation with the governor and
you're going to try to fix his failed
state because you know that there's no
point you just spending money on
infrastructure because it won't be
sustained there's gonna be no point to
spending on health education which then
unless you address the fundamental
problems so what are you gonna start by
doing somebody give me an idea right day
one I've stood up I know in Somalia very
good who's that very good and bring it
okay all right so I'm gonna set up a
horrible thing here called us in there
right okay so this is interesting so ask
his opinion
okay all right let's go on from that
what other things might you be doing yet
okay very good
okay very good okay we got a government
governor who might the other
stakeholders beat let's have some
stakeholders yep okay it's kind of Maire
Church is very good very good yep yep
let's put a church a mosque yeah women
okay let's just pause on this for
sickness they're very interesting how
are you facilitating that how are you
setting about working out how are you
meeting these people how are you getting
them in the room okay we need the census
okay census data alright got an infantry
okay so we got our data we've got our
infantry I'm going to come back to some
of the problems around this but it's
it's a good model right data of a tree
we've got our stakeholders who's we've
consulting so I don't know we've got a
let's let's say that we've got it but
let's let's put this into pompous
language here and then I'm going to put
it up right so we're we're mapping
internal and external stakeholders
right we're defining critical tasks
we're mobilizing resources and finally
to finish with my jargon we are
measuring through iterative monitoring
well we're also threatening people
that's interesting with threatening
people are getting threatened feel good
okay let's come back to that but that's
very good okay I like that
power all right okay
No let me just start on this because
this is actually a very interesting
what's going on on the right hand the
left hand side of this board of men
right
the traditional model of international
development which has been driven
basically for the last 40 years is not
doing what this room and Yale is doing
right you're an unusual audience the
traditional way in which international
development thinks about this is not
like that the traditional way that
international development thinks about
this is in terms of three things right
it thinks about problems in terms of
best practice capacity building and
political will these are the three
things right so the normal idea is that
you turn up in Somalia you bring your
best practice from Vietnam or wherever
it happens to be right you then do your
capacity building of the governor right
and then you wait for his political will
to implement your wonderful best
practice that you've done the festival
know contained within that of course
this is true of almost all International
Development is an insult all you have to
do is turn those phrases around to see
the insult so basically what you're
saying if you say somebody needs best
practice capacity-building and political
will is you're basically saying that
they are ignorant unskilled and idle
right and that your job is to provide
the knowledge the training and a bit of
bit of both now here on the other hand
this audience in Yale has generated a
different kind of model where you have
focused much more on existing power
relationships that are already there on
the ground right and this is absolutely
central to the problem in international
development so if you look at zambia for
example where we have just wasted a
prodigious 55 million on trying to do
reform of agricultural subsidies right
and we've been trying to do this for
over 20 years trying to reform the
agricultural subsidy system so it's a
classic international development
situation some economist turns up they
say one of the reasons why the economy
in Zambia is not going well is because
they are subsidizing agricultural inputs
too much they're wasting an enormous
amount of money on this we can
reallocate it to much more efficient
uses so we're going to bring in a
brilliant economist who's gonna sit down
with the Ministry of Finance he's going
to explain how agricultural subsidies
were removed in Egypt and by doing so
we're going to unlock economic growth in
Tanzania and everything will be fine so
we need the best practice from Egypt we
do the capacity-building in the Ministry
of Finance and then nothing happens
right and why does nothing happen we'd
say it's a lack of political will right
but in fact we're wrong right what's
gone wrong is exactly all the stuff that
you've just identified here what's gone
wrong is that we haven't understood
power relationships in the case of
Zambia and agricultural subsidies we
haven't understood the fact that the
entire government owns land and
therefore most of the major Minister's
involved in decision-making are
themselves receiving these agricultural
subsidies and therefore may be quite
reluctant to have them removed let me
give you another question right to try
to get back
into this stuff I went to see two
projects first one was in Ethiopia and
second one was in another sub-saharan
African country and they were identical
projects right they were both projects
which were about 27 million pounds for
rural health clinics I turn up in
Ethiopia at my rural health clinic it's
busy there are doctors there there are
nurses there there are young volunteers
working on sex education seeing about
27,000 patients a year there are
fantastic patient records there are
great medicines on the shelves I then
turn up in the second country an
absolutely identical program same amount
of money same implementing partners same
model and I turn up in the clinic and
there's human excrement on the floor
there's no medicines on the shelves
there are no patient records there's a
fan but there's no electricity to power
it and of course there are no patients
and sane enough to go anywhere near that
clinic right okay so what is the
difference between the successful
example in Ethiopia and the unsuccessful
example in the other country does anyone
want to generate some thoughts warning
so what's what's going wrong so I've
given 27 minutes here at the Capitol and
here's the question what's gone wrong
between that 27 million and the clinic
some corruption okay
so how does the corruption work this so
we got it we got corruption but give me
an example of where the corruptions
going where the money's going okay so we
lose some here central governments so
the Ministry of Health scoops off about
5% of this money they need some money in
order to do what with it what would the
Minister of Health want to be doing with
this money it is sorry very good very
good I like this audience okay right
this is very important to understand
which is that the corruption is not
always as one could imagine buying the
jacuzzi right often the way that we
misunderstand corruption is we imagine
in these countries that actually what's
happening is the person stealing the
money trouser ring it and buying
themselves a nice property in London or
a Rolls Royce now that does happen of
course right but that is not the major
form of corruption that you're having to
deal with right so we had a very good
example there siphoned off for urban
hospitals why is it been siphoned off
for urban hospitals please know budgets
why is he got a low budget for urban
hospitals correct because some some guy
like me has decided I want to put my 27
million into the raw hospitals and none
of the other donors had decided to put
any money into urban hospitals because
they've done a needs assessment where
they've concluded that it's the rural
population their needs the money even
more than that we may have even decided
on erroneous theological basis that
primary health care is more important
than hospitals so we're not giving any
money to hospitals right but he may want
to continue to run the urban hospitals
so he's stealing some of my money to put
it in an urban hospitals what what other
things
right yep he's not visiting the rural
areas why is that okay maybe he's an
educated person who went studied at Yale
comes from an elite family like many of
the people that would have been in his
government he probably doesn't spend
much time in the rural areas and it's
not a huge priority to him because these
people are not likely to vote for him
right okay so that's another thing that
he might be putting the money in pick so
he needs to or so possibly can make a
contribution towards his own political
party he needs to get some money
together in order to get some votes get
some people out delivering some leaflets
make sure people are in certifies to
come in and vote okay
so there's some money that's gone
missing at the center right next bit of
money is going to go missing at the
district level anyone like to suggest
where the money's gone at the district
Wow beautiful
salaries why has he got to steal the
money to pay the salaries he is not
collecting taxes
he's not collecting taxes which means
that he has to get the money from the
international donor and what does the
international donor not want to give
them money for salaries right we hate
the idea of giving money for salaries
because it doesn't feel like it's
sustainable we worry that if we start
supporting people's salaries there's
going to be no end of it so we want to
start investing in some innovative small
clinic but we don't want to be paying
the salary bill because we don't really
feel that's our job right meanwhile the
medicines okay I'm trying to get my head
around why are the drugs not on the
shelves in this place right why are the
no rather no drugs on the shelves and
the drugs have been imported into the
country we believe right some nice
American company has got the contract
for pharmaceuticals there are contracts
or invoices the receipts the
pharmaceuticals have arrived right why
have they not made it onto the shelves
here sorry so yet some has been stolen
yes lack of refrigeration very good
beautiful remember why I've got that fan
up there which we spent a lot of money
installing but there's no electricity
within 10 miles of this place so you
can't refrigerate anything Reds who is
supposed to be getting the
pharmaceuticals into that place I mean
his that she's job is it to get it from
the capital city from the airport to the
clinic hospital administrator or
possibly a contract has been issued to
somebody right maybe somebody's want a
contract in order to deliver it but they
don't deliver on the contract what do
you do when they don't deliver on the
contract are they your cousin are they
from your political party what kind of
sanctions have you got or does it turn
out that the person who's in charge of
actually running the dispensary in the
clinic has their own private dispensary
in the same village into which the
medicines have no pity
okay not promised you were coming
towards an end here right okay now let's
get back to our fixing our state so
we've just been here in health I want to
keep generating other things that you
want to do in order to fix this state
right what are the other things that you
feel the state needs in order to operate
so we've got security so we got
legitimate monopoly on the use of
violence I'm going to turn this into
jargon right we've got an effective
civil service got a decent financial
administration somebody mentioned tax
we've got health and investor education
so we're investing in human capital to
get the jargon together beautiful
beautiful beautiful beautiful beautiful
beautiful
so judiciary I'm gonna put it here as
the rule of law rule and maybe citizen's
rights how are we gonna get the economy
going what do we need to get the economy
going huh Michael let's Michael let's
discuss in my credits maybe we need a
pragmatically regulated free market
maybe we need some bias but so you need
a market of some sort yeah somebody who
understands the culture there that's
more about
yeah okay
no the next problem
is who are you right so you've arrived
in this place you're advising the
governor you're trying to do all this
stuff who actually are you right and
what are your problems right you as
UNICEF you as the World Food Program you
as the World Bank you as USAID you as a
Yale University professor off on a four
months right
okay what are the problems that you face
stealing with this government give me
one problem you don't speak the language
correct this is not a trivial problem
this is not a trivial problem there is a
conceit in the international community
that you don't need to speak the local
language there's some idea that the
people that matter speak English the
fact is in almost every developing
country that simply is not true and
certainly outside the capital city it
definitely is not true and yet the
statistics on this absolutely horrifying
so in 2011 the height of the surge in
Afghanistan when there were a hundred
and twenty thousand international
soldiers and 100,000 I could you not 100
thousand international civilian
consultants right so nearly 220,000
foreigners on the ground there were
approximately 100 of those people who
could speak in Afghan language fluently
it approximately 100 the the scale of
this problem is inconceivable right and
that lack of linguistic understanding of
course is also a deep deep lack of
cultural understanding I mean absolutely
no idea whatsoever
about the context so we are now
including myself Ernest turning up in
this country we are experts on
governance in the abstract we are
experts on gender in the abstract we are
experts on education in the abstract on
economics in the abstract what we are
not experts on is gender in Afghanistan
education in Afghanistan the economics
of Afghanistan because we don't know
anything about Afghanistan we don't know
any matter of Kansas and we don't speak
the language
why else don't we know anything about
Afghanistan correct we don't have any
relationships to get us into doors and
what is the reason why we don't have any
relationships or one fundamental
structural logistical problem transient
so short-term relationships there so
short-term very very serious problem
right so the average tour length of an
American soldier in Afghanistan was 12
months the average length of a British
soldier was 6 months the average tour
length of an Italian soldier was 4
months the average diplomatic posting
was 12 months extendable to 2 years
right and then the next problem is what
what's the next problem when you want to
go out and visit your governor and spend
time in that place security right
there's an insurgency going on people
are trying to kill you people are trying
to blow you up you can only move around
in an armored vehicle you want to go and
see the Department of Education to have
a discussion of the direction of
Education you go along in two armored
vehicles with four bodyguards who tell
you that you can be in that office for
an hour and a half before they have to
extract you because they're worried that
somebody's gonna come and kill you how
easy is it right you turn up with your
translator because you don't speak the
language you're there for a very short
term period you're actually if you're a
civilian almost certainly getting leave
for two weeks every
six weeks where you're removed from the
country decide to stop you go crazy so
there's absolutely no continuity of
anyone dealing with it and you can only
spend an hour and a half from the
person's office and you're a fantastic
okay so then there are these whole
issues around bureaucracies right the
issues around the stovepipe the issues
around the incentives of bureaucracies
right then what happens when you are the
person on the ground so you're out there
on the ground and you pretty rapidly
determine that nothing very useful is
getting done here you're not really
achieving very much right but you're
sending your reports back to your boss
right and there are one of two problems
with saying that you're not achieving
very much on the ground right a one
problem is that you're I don't know
you're a middle-aged South African
consultant trying to get away from your
wife and you're slightly worried that
you might be sent back to South Africa
if you keep sending in reports saying
things about getting very far or the
second problem is somebody said there is
an existential threat to global security
here if Afghanistan Falls Pakistan will
fall mad mullahs will get their hands on
nuclear weapons right at which point
failures not an option
so visit which brings us to the politics
so back home somebody's got an idea of
what they're trying to do with this
place I try to simplify it initially by
suggesting that back home you could
provide a humanitarian explanation for
what you're doing in sub-saharan Africa
and a national security explanation for
what you're doing in sub-saharan Africa
but the reality is that the political
justifications in Washington or in
London or in Paris alerting around them
changing very very rapidly I mean almost
more rapidly than you can keep up with
them I remember feeling this very
strongly when I was challenging the
surge in Afghanistan right I remember in
2011 we had the British Embassy in Kabul
as the largest British Embassy in the
world and I said what on earth do you
think you're doing why on earth have you
got the largest embassy in the world in
Afghanistan I mean if if you're worried
about terrorism Pakistan it's more
important if you're worried about
regional security the Middle East is
more important if you're worried about
poverty sub-saharan Africa is more
important what on earth are you doing
with the largest embassy in the world
and Afghanistan and the answer was low
key of F garrison Falls Pakistan will
for Mad mullahs will get their hands on
nuclear weapons this next era global
security right 2013 and I go to a
meeting and they tell me that they're
reducing the size the Embassy in Kabul
so it's going to become the second
smallest embassy that we have in that
part of Asia I said what are you doing
why you were juicing it's so small it's
gonna be smaller than the pool where are
we going with this and then they say to
me ah Rory if you're worried about
terrorism Pakistan matters more than
Afghanistan run on it
right the whole thing moves like this so
who knows whether at one time or another
what you're really concerned about here
is human rights democracy and a full
rich thick sense or whether you're only
concerned about holding elections who
knows whether what you're really
concerned about is defeating the Taliban
or whether what you all really care
about is killing Osama bin Laden who
knows whether your government actually
buys into that whole theory that I hope
just sketched on Africa about migration
about
epidemics about Labor potential about
raw materials or whether the government
is just committed to spending 0.7
percent of its GDP on international aid
and is trying to find somewhere to park
that money and this presupposes of
course that the politicians themselves
have any clear answers to these
questions the answer of course the
politicians not being a highly
distinguished room in Yale may be quite
busy people with many other things to
think about it may not have a fully
analyzed and worked out logical theory
on exactly what their position is on the
Central African Republic or exactly what
they believe about the RO hinga and
Myanmar and the question of whether
they're going to be focusing this week
on Yemen or this week on South Sudan may
have nothing to do with the objective
conditions on the ground in Yemen or
South Sudan or may have a great deal
more to do with what happens to be in
the newspapers right now let me try to
wrap this up and then then move on to
questions so I began by saying that I
came in as a new minister into
international development and I touched
the edge of this wonderful idealistic
vision which we carry with us of the
transformation of other people's
countries so the transformation of very
poor countries transformation of
countries that are going through
humanitarian catastrophes I talked about
the failures of development since the
1970s and talked about some of the
reasons why we feel development has
failed we then began together as a joint
exercise to sketch out conceptually what
is involved in trying to describe the
business of fixing a failed state a
little bit of an attempt to describe
what an ideal state might look like and
what the methodology might be in
achieving it which is where we generated
this mapping of internal and external
stakeholders the definition of critical
tasks the mobilization of sufficient
resource and the measuring through
iterative monitoring we created ten
functions with state right ranging from
the legitimate monopoly on the use of
violence through a good civil service a
good financial administration investment
citizens rights and responsibilities
investment in human capital
infrastructure good management
that's international regulations
pragmatically regulated free-market and
the rule of law right and then we talks
about the problems and trying to flesh
those things out so we took the example
of Health and corruption and health and
the problems of getting those those
drugs through to the clinic then we
touched on who we are it took a little
bit about us in there and if we can come
back to us in them in a second but who
we are who we are as individuals right
what languages do we speak where are we
based how long we there what kind of
security constraints do we face talked a
little bit about of bureaucratic
structures what is it in the culture of
bureaucracies that makes it difficult to
mesh or interact and then we reflected
on the political the strange political
lurches within the brains the
politicians which brings us back to the
fundamental problem the fundamental
problem is that in many many many cases
we are dedicating ourselves to
impossible projects and projects which
we cannot acknowledge as impossible
because we find it very difficult to
take on board leaving aside the ethical
issues leaving aside the deep moral
problems for the intervention we cannot
take on board the sheer practical the
sheer practical implications of putting
yourself in that governor's office in a
remote part of Somalia trying to turn
around a society when a civil war is
going on when there's no electricity on
the ground and where you don't begin to
understand the local structures where
all these things that you've mentioned
if I can get
the importance of data the importance of
an inventory the importance of trying to
map who these stakeholders are the
census all these things are close to
impossible for you to achieve there is
no data in that part of Somalia the
records have been blown up or destroyed
you have no way of getting your
researchers out into the field you're
not there for long enough you simply
cannot gather that information the
stakeholders that you unfortunately end
up seeing end up unless you're very very
careful being a very very arbitrary
group of people dominated by tribal
chiefs who turn up and say I am the
chief of this tribe this tribe follows
me in the next day somebody else turns
up and says my cousin's bluffing he's
not the chief of the tribe I'm the chief
of the tribe and the women that you are
trying to deal with right your women
that you're trying to interact with in
my case what trying to do this kind of
consultation in Amara in Iraq we set up
a Provincial Council in which all the
women sat at one end of the room in
total silence where their head scarves
on didn't contribute to the political
conversation at all and then when one of
them spoke up she was dragged out of her
car and executed the next day right so
the extremity of the problems you're
dealing with the problems again of me my
self dealing with Haider and Iraq who
was a young human rights activist who I
helped finance his children's magazine
and who I employed as a translator who
was himself dragged from his car and
executed by the Sarris militia because
he was working with me ranks problems
which I haven't begun to touch on here
which go beyond this
which are problems of legitimacy
problems and what happens when an
insurgency is going on problems when a
country perceives you as a foreign
occupying force put all that together
and then take on board the fact that
sometimes these interventions work and
I'm going to finish for this because I
want to finish on a slightly more
optimistic note before we get on to
questions in Bosnia when I arrived there
first 1994 that country had faced a war
in which over a hundred thousand people
have been killed in which nearly a
million people have been displaced from
their homes as refugees in which there
were a hundred and fifty thousand people
under arms in which there were about 85
checkpoints between Sarajevo and a town
100 miles north of Sarajevo in which war
criminals like melodic were on the loose
carriage which was on the LEAs we
intervened United States playing this
very major part of it Richard Holbrooke
playing as a former lecturer Atlas in
this lecture series played a very major
part and within five years five years a
very short period of time against all
the ants a million houses had been
returned to their original owners the
killing had stopped the checkpoints had
disappeared the hundred and fifty
thousand people under arms had been
reduced to 16,000 under arms the war
criminals had almost all been arrested
and have since been prosecuted in The
Hague and the crime rate in Bosnia is
today lower than Sweden right that is a
success which is why the challenge for
all of us moving forward is to try to
work out how to combine the deep
pessimism that might emerge from this
kind of analysis with the strong
understanding that it can be done that
it was done in Bosnia to a lesser extent
in Kosovo in Sierra Leone
in Cambodia and that if we can often do
much less than we pretend we can do much
more than we fear thank you very much
indeed good thank you all very much
questions okay so China in relation to
Africa is very very difficult for the
West the presence so we don't know
exactly how much China has spent in
Africa over the last twenty years maybe
seventy five billion maybe a hundred
billion dollars maybe more because
you're having to count the money that is
spent directly by the Chinese government
money sent by state-owned enterprises
money spent by Chinese private
businesses the Chinese involvement in
Africa is very deep so many African
countries now you'll turn up there may
be as many as 150,000 Chinese citizens
settled in the country performing basic
agricultural tasks running shops getting
involved in construction go to someone
like Zimbabwe
the airport has been paid for by China
the National Training College for the
military has been paid for by China go
to Ethiopia most of the major road
network has been installed and paid for
by China and so you will find African
leaders saying that they are very keen
that the United States or Britain
behaved more like China right there are
African leaders who say to me that we
don't want you coming in and talking
about human rights we don't want you to
a civil society we don't want you
talking about democratization what we
would like you to do is build us some
roads build our Parliament building for
us build our Airport for us and above
all invest we'd like some money coming
into the country to get some jobs no at
the same time there are other African
leaders who are beginning to get very
frustrated with China and are beginning
to feel that China has exploited and
abuse that the Chinese model has been
very one-sided and there are people in
China who are beginning to feel that
they've lost a lot of money in Africa
but most of the loans they've made in
Africa a lot of the investment they've
planted where Africa isn't going to come
good these projects are never going to
return the kind of investment they've
put in and where they are discovering as
we all discover the limits of the kind
of power I mean it's not quite clear
what China is doing here and one of the
answers this may be that China doesn't
necessarily need to answer that question
because their economy is growing so fast
they've got so much money they don't
need to really worry about it I mean
when people in Britain challenged me and
say what's China doing spending all this
money why are you not out competing
China the answer is the Chinese economy
it's currently growing every year and a
half about the size of the entire
British economy so they've got a certain
amount of surplus money to be putting
into these kinds of projects but are
they doing it in order to try to gain
strategic advantage over war materials
possibly so current estimates suggest I
was waving my iPhone around that China
currently owns about 75% of the world's
coltan about 78 percent of the world's
cobalt and about 85 percent of the world
rare earths so one way of interpreting
this is this is a smart bet that these
are the things that are going to matter
for those objects of the future and
China needs to put a marker down on
those things and then the question funny
even if you wanted to be China what
would American or British populations
make of their governments trying to
behave like China so as a working
politician of course my experience every
day in Parliament is turning up and
being challenged why are you not
intervening in the Civil War in Burundi
and I have to stand up and say in a
slightly pompous way we call on Burundi
to respect UN resolution whatever we
call on them to respect the Arusha
Accords we call on them to work with the
EX Tanzanian Prime Minister who's
currently gone out my sit down and then
somebody else stands up and says what
are you doing to resolve the situation
in western Cameroon and then I have to
stand up and say we call on the
Anglophone community of west Cameroon to
resolve their political differences with
the francophone community and in the end
the only solution to the conflict is
through a political solution but we call
on everyone to respect the Constitution
return glance and I sit down again and
thanks guys 6000 says what are you doing
about the situation and Togo right the
point that I'm trying to make here is
that my political culture doesn't enable
me to say what a Chinese diplomat would
say to me which is frankly I don't
really have a dog in the fight of who's
winning in Bern D I don't really have
any control about what's happening in
West Cameroon and I'm not going to
pretend to my public that these things
are either things I can do much about
all things that we have a particular
national interest in pursuing so I think
those were some questions in response to
China rotten answers on China but it was
a good question
okay so Botswana is a really really
interesting example and Botswana you
know went from being down there with
Malawi one of the poorest countries in
the world in the 1960s to now being a
middle-income country in Africa a
middle-income country with very little
corruption which was not destroyed by a
resource curse the normal idea is that
if you are cursed with oil or diamonds
you get a Dutch disease and you're in a
terrible trouble but in fact what's what
I was able to manage its diamonds it's
been able to get very very good figures
not just some things like education but
on things like fertility rates so where
it's in Nazaire the average family size
is about 7.2 and Botswana they've
managed to get it down to about 3.4 a
month
now these are very very impressive
achievements that have happened in
Botswana and it's not immediately
obvious what it is about Botswana that's
allowing to do it let's move on to
another couple of cases Rwanda Ethiopia
right these are these are even more
controversial Botswana it's one that we
feel quite comfortable with because it's
a democratic country where there have
been nice democratic transitions every
eight years
but Rwanda Ethiopia very interesting so
Rwandan Ethiopia of course if I had been
doing this talk in in the late 1980s
would have been right up there on the
West amongst the five poorest countries
in the world and Ethiopia coast went
through a famine and of course in 1994
Rwanda went through this horrifying
genocide since that time those countries
through very authoritarian governments
have managed to double the GDP per
capita of their countries and Rwanda is
genuinely remarkable Ethiopia is
genuinely remarkable I mean there are
huge questions around the style of
government but my goodness you walk into
the clinics they're working you look at
the roads they were repaired it's clean
its progressive a lot of the investments
bearing fruit even these strange
governments state-owned enterprises that
we don't really understand we want to
sort of suggest that everybody should be
following a Botswana model one on
private enterprise in fact ruonan
Ethiopia a lot of the money is spent by
the army and yet seems to be effectively
spent by the army and been getting
actual returns for people in those
countries but do we have any real way of
explaining why that's working in Rwanda
and it's not working in Burundi and
Burundi is basically a perfect
comparison to Rwanda their histories are
almost identical their geology is their
geographies the ethnic divisions between
Tutsi and Hutu are almost identical
between the two countries and yet one of
them is taken off and the other one is
mine and miserable poverty and is
sitting there is number three on my list
so the answer on Rwandan Ethiopia is
supposed to be the inheritance of
medieval state structures so the
theoretical answer that's proposed at
the moment is that somehow they're
drawing off a deep legacy of state
control under an old Rwandan Kingdom and
under the Ethiopian King none of that of
course applies to Botswana at all right
that had none of those structures in
place which is where you end up in this
horrible question around leadership and
of course this question saying this is
about leadership or saying this is about
um avoiding corruption is simply a
tautology and it's completely empty
statement because it poses the prior
question of well what style of
leadership what is it that allowed it to
involve corruption in fact a lot of what
we proposed as explanations and not
really explanations at all they're just
other ways of stating the obvious I mean
the classic example on corruption let's
say we say how did Botswana avoid
corruption right and the traditional
answer to that is through transparent
predictable and accountable financial
processes right there doesn't tell you
anything right right to say that a to
say that a country has transparent
predictable
furnished press is just another way of
saying it's not corrupt it doesn't help
you get anywhere closer to the core
explanation so the answer is I'm sorry
confused and if you have an idea or an
explanation I'd like forth but the the
basic story is that in in almost every
developing country to provide us a sort
of slick answer that is that it's much
much easier to provide a convincing
explanation of success than it is of
failure
Renault buddy can ever explain failure
and you saw that most variable in the
comparison between the search in Iraq
and the search in Afghanistan when the
search in iraq worked General Petraeus
provided a very clear explanation for
why it worked when his certain
Afghanistan failed there was no
explanation at all
and that are working as much as possible
[Applause]
okay so this is a really really central
point okay
mobile telephones are a very good
example of something that seems to work
almost everyone right the first big
success not just in Somalia but in
Afghanistan was the mobile telephone
system the second thing that the
international community whatever the
hell that means
seems to be able to do in these
countries is stabilize the currents in
set up a central bank right first thing
they did in Bosnia their best thing
about central banks stable currency
cabal's stable currency central bank
Baghdad stable currency central banker
what do these things have in common
right the mobile telephone system the
stable currency the central bank
generally what they have in common is
they're quite techie engineering issues
they're generally things that foreigners
sitting in a capital bringing best
practice from somewhere else in the
world are able to deliver right they're
not deeply rooted in complex issues of
culture tribalism governance the rule of
law civil society in fact it's one of
the reasons why the Gates Foundation I
believe is increasingly focused on
health rather than education because
certain kinds of health interventions in
particular immunization appears to be
relatively standard across many of these
different kind
and it's relatively straightforward for
the Gates Foundation to send out people
you know how to do immunization turn up
in a country and really achieve some
very dramatic improvements in health
indicators when it comes to education ah
highly politicized the teachers union
the curriculum the low status of
teachers the way a rural school operates
girls boys all this kind of thing they
are scary so what do we do with this
fact what do we do with the fact that
there are certain kinds of things that
we seem to be able to do well mobile
phones Bank some aspects of health care
and other things which seem to us more
fundamental more important but which we
really struggle to deal with rule of law
governance corruption my instinct is
focus on that right because I don't
think you can do this stuff generally it
can be done right people within those
countries can themselves sort out those
problems in different ways Botswana
Rwanda sorted out those problems
Bangladesh is an extraordinary example
of a country which if I'd been talking
to you in 1976 was the definitional
basket case you know a country where
150,000 people could be killed in the
single incidence of flooding today their
flood emergency response is so good that
she would probably only lose 500 people
in a similar scale flood and they're on
the verge of becoming a middle-income
country and the employment rates have
rocketed and education rates and
rocketed and the microcredit schemes of
work etc so countries can begin to sort
out some of these things Bangladesh
perhaps not a great example sorting out
those particular things I read on the on
the right wall but other things they
have sorted out but I do not think these
are things that farmers are going to be
very good at sorting out and the
is because of all these kinds of things
it's because of who foreigners are I
mean the people that are likely to be
able to deal with these root problems of
rule of law governance corruption are
going to be people from within that
culture in particular local political
leaders we talked about us and them and
the fundamental problem for us in them
if I can find it again which I can't is
that generally in the way in which we
have thought about other people's
countries we have over emphasized us and
we've under emphasized them we've tended
to assume that we are heroic brilliant
intervenors with all this best practice
that's going to come and do the
capacity-building and that they are a
little bit foolish right
generally the places that have worked
Bosnia's are a good example of this
they worked for exactly the reasons that
we thought they wouldn't work right so
we thought the problem in Bosnia was
that the foreign military was not more
active in fact in Bosnia the secret was
that the forum actually wasn't more
active because it gave more space to the
local political actors we thought the
problem in Bosnia was that too many
deals were cut with extremist political
parties almost certainly giving the
responsibility to local political actors
and forcing them to cut deals with
extremist political parties is actually
what led to the political solution in
Bosnia right so it's there that's going
to be able to sort that stuff out and
it's us
that should try to focus on the things
that we can do right which is why I am
quite a believer just to annoy everybody
in this room even more in humanitarian
relief work right
obviously humanitarian relief work
sounds done humanitarian relief work
sounds absurd right what on earth are
you doing providing cash transfers or
shelter or food to starving people
surely what you should be doing is
addressing the deep underlying root
structural issues that caused the famine
in the first place and you should be
creating the sustainable economic
development so that you don't have to do
that so that the country concerned can
do it now of course logically that's
true of course if a country is able to
do what China did I'd get itself into
the state of wealth that China's in now
it doesn't need any humanitarian relief
or anybody to look after itself in fact
in get around providing humanitarian
leave to other people's countries but I
don't think that we can do that we in
this room right and insofar as we can't
do that then I think it's just such a
very good idea to go around providing
humanitarian assistance to people and
not worrying too much about the fact
that we haven't addressed the root
causes that led to it so yeah I'll
provide shorter answers I'm sorry
yeah yeah so this I think is what the
German was probably getting onto and
that's exactly right so of course the
point is to then think deeply about the
way in which you might be able to use
something like the setting up of a good
mobile telephony system in Somalia to
achieve many other things and that could
be in the case of Kenya of course the
impasto system on banking it could be a
very good project I saw in Northeast
Nigeria which was using weather data in
order to create good simple insurance
models for farmers with their crops it
could be in the case of Somalia actually
beginning to get information out about
the famine and the drought through the
use of those mobile telephones so you're
absolutely right I mean the secret is
focus on what we can do and then making
the most of what we can do but that
still will fall short of being able to
address some of the issues that will
continue to fill a phone about to the
lady at the backyard
try to work to solve them because
okay yeah nominated but the point is a
very very fundamental one and it's a
fundamental problem with my position
right it's a fundamental problem with my
position so essentially what's being
said there is look if these countries
genuinely pose a serious threat to
global security then what I'm proposing
here isn't going to cut it because
essentially what I'm saying is that
these countries here those five
countries on the left and most those
countries on the right are probably
likely in 25 50 years time most of them
still to be quite poor quite fragile
quite traumatized still have quite a lot
of um government space still have quite
a lot of areas that are likely to either
generate regional conflicts and Wars or
perhaps in the worst case generate on
government space where terrorists could
stifle push large amounts of migrants
through into Europe if the population if
40 percent of the children born in the
world by 2050 are going to be in
sub-saharan Africa and if they're going
to be no jobs in sub-saharan Africa then
it seems perfectly plausible that by
2050 you you could of course have 150
200 300 million Africans trying to move
into Europe so of course what I'm saying
in that sense is quite pessimistic I'm
saying that we can't I'm afraid create
jobs for those people we don't know how
to do it if we knew how to create jobs
for 18 million Africans a year we
wouldn't have the problems we have in
Greece and Spain at the Monde
yeah we should be we should be planning
for the worst-case scenario we should be
assuming that we do not have it within
us to achieve the kind of radical
transformations we're not going to be
able to create full employment in Africa
we're not going to be able to turn
Malawi in the next 50 years into South
Korea I mean I don't think right and
therefore we need a plan for the worst
at the same time we also need to be
aware of the fact that maybe the threat
posed is not as Extreme as we sometimes
suggest that often things that we say
our existential threats to global
security may not be existential threats
to global security we may present them
as such because and I feel this as a
politician because we're trying to
justify our aid budget or explain to the
public why we're spending all this money
on international aid so we tend to
overemphasize the threats that could be
posed and I good point right I'll stop
oh well I'll take two and I'll send
together thank you thank you yeah sir
back
hey Charlene question something law for
the right path I said as I said that was
so this beautiful beautifully
beautifully instead it I I think I'm
gonna dodge that one I think it's
slightly off the subject to think but
maybe we could talk about it afterwards
they were a drink I'm happy to do that
um okay let me let me finish on the on
the question that's been post around
East Timor Kosovo Bosnia um I suppose
I'm company I suppose my gut instinct is
that number one we were wrong or people
were wrong who concluded in Iraq for
example that cumbersome UN coalition
operations are inferior to us led
coalition's with a much more aggressive
military posture in many ways the things
that seemed so frustrating in those
countries which are that troops in
Bosnia were very reluctant to deploy
from their bases as was true in Kosovo
too there were more injuries to American
soldiers on the baseball court in
Sarajevo than were suffered in any form
of contact with the enemy
right in retrospect were virtues because
they actually compelled local political
actors to play the role and and and
rebuild their own societies the useful
role played by the military is often in
these situations in Kosovo for example
were moving behind cost of our civil
society organizations that were moving
to do refugee return with the troops
coming along behind them and then
drawing back and they're moving forward
in the costs case of Kosovo and Bosnia
two very very important to understand
that we the international community are
one factor alongside other perhaps more
important factors I've mentioned local
leadership but also regional power
politics what the neighbors are doing
what the European Union was able to
offer as a carrot to draw people in on
East Timor on Cambodia is beginning to
push outside my area
expertise but I would say that my gut
instinct is that the light footprint
approach is the correct one that the
surge is almost always a mistake because
the surge is generally an attempt by the
foreigner through massive deployment of
resources and troops to impose their
will on a recalcitrant situation the
only hope of success I think has to be
the light footprint that necessarily
forces local political actors to take
the lead in other words to conclude in
relation to all of this probably as
indeed with the much of the rest of the
world the wisdom is the wisdom of
humility humility is endless thank you
very much
[Applause]
[Music]